the numbers on the pitcher la piedra
luis castillo the biggest numbers lark
his woes in the first inning in first
innings he has an era approaching 20.
it's grounded teeth of the shift a big
hop but farmer handles one away
swinging a miss
the bald is dancing for castillo early
well that was the good change of right
there and you can see that that ball
starts in the strike zone and the break
and the depth on the breaking ball of
the change up has it run out of the
strikes on one two
swing and a miss
the best first inning of the year for
luis castillo
and perhaps an olmen of what's to come a
couple of k's and the reds grabbed their
backs
davey's era at just under nine and a
half
worst of his career of any five-game
stretch and naked goes gapping that
clangs off the wall
tyler naik with a stand-up double
crack to third backhand pick long
one-footed throw way off line
castellanos turns naquin rumbles over to
third base the ball gathered the wave is
on the fire to the pike the
well ball down the third base line
and you can see bodhi with the nice
attempt but definitely offline and
there's not much rizzo can do
and naquin running hard
he's got to see that ball through
and here's the speed
now mustache gets a chance to drive him
in with the fly ball
ustakas clubs this one in the air to
right hayward back
at the wall makes the catch tag at third
castellanos
crosses zach fly rbi two nothing rigs
[Applause]
the swing and a miss davies gets the
punch out and that's the inning luis
castillo returns the bound after working
a one two three first inning
and there's strike three cole
three k's for castillo
well we mentioned the fast balls early
in the competitive pitch you can see the
change of grip
go from 99 98 miles an hour to 88 mile
an hour and
pitching on both sides of the plate
swing and a miss
the miss there comes from the stick four
strikeouts for a dominant castillo
louise castillo will face the bottom of
the order for the cubs now the 2-2 to
horner
and he lines it down the right-field
line that is going to be a fair ball
bouncing into the corner chasing it down
as castigano's nico horner clapping his
hands as he trots into second base with
a standing double
[Music]
there it is base hit picking it up as
naked when horner stops at third and
they're at the corners
[Applause]
good call partner well it's beautiful
baseball right there
davey's capable with the bat in his
hands he got speed on third base it's a
it's a read situation from order it's
not a suicide squeeze it's make sure the
ball gets down one two
swinging a miss
castillo breaks out the off speed his
fifth strikeout of the game and he
strands a man 90 feet away hey eugenio
suarez do up struck out swinging first
time up
one two
swing and a miss struck him out good
meeting got him on the change up suarez
is gone and the reds leave him loaded
nice pitch this game rolls along the top
of the fourth inning leaves castillo
back to work good line toward right
center field that's in the gap base said
it goes all the way to the wall in right
center
senzelle runs it down bodhi trots to
second with a standing two-bagger
hayward turns that one around and hits
it hard into right around third and
coming in is bodhi
and he's safe
racing down to second is hayward couple
of hard hit balls and it's a 2-2 game
well it's good work after two quick outs
bodhi who struck out first time
knocks the double hayward who has good
numbers against castillo gets on top of
this elevated
pitch and rips it to right for an rbi
knock
two guys in hayward and body that have
made a
good amount of hard contact this year
but not seeing a lot of results
2-2
that is over bottom at first
hayward rounds third without a signal
throw home is there the tag
he's out
castianos the dime of the dish and what
a tag by stevenson
they nailed hayward at home play
well cassiano was able to
charge that ball and nice one hop throw
to the plate tyler stevenson doesn't bla
block the path of the runner allows the
ball to take him into that base path and
applies the tag and i think they're
going to review it to see if he actually
did tag it and horner is on here's the
call out
and that is the ending so the base is
loaded again
and nick castellanos
will come up to him and pull another
rabbit out of his hat
3-2 on the way
on the ground horner gobbles it up over
to first and he does
reds leave them loaded
and that is sharply stung into right
field later break for soul guard
gathered and lost by castianos so
guarded stopped now he breaks
throw in relay to third mustache drops
the taggings out
that's a way to stay with the play right
on the helmet
and sogard's indecision froze half who
remains at first
that's exactly what it was right there
indecision
castillanos comes up with the ball
after the bobble
and then you can see the hesitation
from sogart hesitation on the line drive
and then here's the hesitation and then
the late decision to go to third base
good throw from henny good tag
2-2
crush to center
headlong dive in the catch
nick senzel the snow code snare castillo
loves it and that's the ending we talked
about the versatility of nick senzel
you saw the great play yesterday at
shortstop our second base and now in
center field brothers into the game for
the 11th time ground balls and
strikeouts that's the plus for rex and
the one-two
breaking ball got him looking votto knew
it
just carves up joey votto nice
sequencing
really good fastballs and then the
breaking ball locks them up
[Music]
swaying and a miss
and a slider for a strikeout and there's
two away
swing and a miss struck him out rex
brothers comes in and strikes out the
side
so now nicole horner a chance to give
the cubs the lead
lines that one out towards right center
and falls for a hit
coming in to score his bias
racing
[Music]
nico horner delivers and it's 3-2 my
goodness how good has nico horner been
here this afternoon
oh this one's been brewing for a few
years now the prime time matchup that
we said when it first started happening
you're gonna see this for years to come
well here's another edition amir garrett
versus anthony rizzo
sliders swinging to miss strike three
this crowd gets behind a.g
[Applause]
strike three on the slider
and now garrett is barking
at the cubs dugout and both benches
empty
buyers wants garrett garrett wants fires
the bullpen is empty
baez hurdled
the padded railing
and came onto the field in motion to
karen come get me
amir garrett before the at-bat even
started he walked all the mo all the way
almost to the cut of the grass
[Applause]
and you can see after the strikeout
[Applause]
and rizzo after the strikeout just puts
his head down
and just walks
walks to the dugout and
your teammates have got to have your
back
abhi baez said hey
you can't show up our players like that
[Applause]
countianos
makes the catch one two three inning
they pass the baton to the uh the
anchorman on the relay team craig
kimbrell tyler stevenson first pitch he
rips it into center field
well tyler stevenson didn't waste any
time
cracked into right field face hit
hoffman's on to take three hayward
gathers a big hit from barnhart first
and third nobody out cambril the 3-2
and there got him
wow
kimbrell deals
the pitch
tapped on the ground horner collects
ball game cubs win
what a job to wriggle out of that
by craig kimbrell